[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy sunday let's backflip into week 13
like we all have tyreke hill on our
fantasy teams
welcome to the squad ride brought to you
bright by draftkings
live in the bleacher report app my name
is cabbie richards and at the top of the
power rankings
is the young lady in the middle that is
kelly stewart and more hollywood than
anyone named marquise
on the other side of this of her is greg
ivory
uh this is the show where we bet anytime
touchdowns and we sum up a collective
experience with two words
squad ride this week's unfortunately
this week in squad right history is
brought to you by the letter
l aaron jones did not score a touchdown
for us last week so we fall
to eight and four but that's okay we
will bounce back
in week 13. we have a whole new list of
player options
we asked you on br social earlier in the
this week
to drop your pick to score a touchdown
for a shot at winning a br betting
hoodie
we asked you answered and this is the
new list of players
that have been chosen by you the
audience look at the juice on dalvin
cook
mine is 400. and that's when you who put
in miles sanders
taste them hill zach earth
who picked these they're fired the
audience is fired well the audience did
so you're literally talking about
a hundred thousand people uh we have
five legendary videos to show you uh
for our squad ride this week and
congrats
to all of you guys who backdoor covered
with the ravens against the steelers
and the eagles against seattle because
this montage hits us right here
all right one more play just knock it
down
knock it down and get the cover seattle
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i lost everything
it's a special kind of hopelessness to
lose on a backdoor cover and if you're
one of those people that bet on seattle
kelly stewart has a few choice words for
you cabbie was that our big boss joe
there at the end
he's lost everything i've been preaching
about money mandarin for a long time i
feel like he knows better
than that to lose everything on a
terrible
number you guys have no one but
yourselves to blame
five and a half six available with my
dudes at draftkings
all week long if you laid six and a half
that is your
fault you have no one but yourself to
blame my psa is over
all right well thank you for your ted
talk uh i also am one of those people
that uh
that pick seattle so uh greg avery i
don't know if you're gonna call my name
but if you
pick seattle and if greg ivory calls
your name in this next little part
maybe that'll help you feel better greg
where are you gonna find these folks
though
cabbie you know where i'm at i'm in the
comments
uh actually let's talk about that that
seattle game though uh
i'm actually rejoicing in that because i
had the eagles so
shout out to carson wench in the hail
mary yes
yes we covered on that we covered on
that
i was feeling good but let me feel even
more good by giving away some hoodies
in these comments uh okay here we go i
got chris paul goat sands tyreke hill
is the way to go that man is an animal
yes tyreek hill went absolutely crazy
last week
he went crazy last week that's deserving
of a hoodie cabbie
um i'm back into the comments t-y versus
houston he
owns that stadium
oh t y t
why he's on my fantasy team i
like that play dave brady you're walking
away with a hoodie cabbie you know what
that's it that's it for right now that's
it for right now let's let's get on
let's you know
i'll be back perfect we got a lot of
show left so let's get week 13
started the videos will face off you
guys get in the comments let us know
which ones move off
uh move on our first a pitch comes from
loge mabry logan who do you got scoring
a touchdown this week
for my um sunday locks for an anytime tv
score
i'm going to go with zach hurts tight
i'm going back to the build up
use
word of advice for this nova never
overplay your stroke okay our his and
our his our next pitch comes from zach
13
who has a good feeling about his pick
we got anytime scorers laid out for
tomorrow naeem hines
travis kelsey taysom hill darren waller
miles sanders devonte adams
larry legend if he's in and the dolphins
defense
and iverson's gonna come in iverson
here retreat
here we go here we go here we go
oh devonta adams lock it in
he had to walk far for that one that's a
good boy right there uh it's rare that
we have players
featured in the same game but that's how
we're starting week 13 so we have zach
ertz
of the philadelphia eagles devonta adams
of the green bay packers let us know how
you feel about these videos
in the comments uh g money what do you
think about our first matchup
cabbie uh we got zach ertz devonte adams
let's talk about the dr evil
uh legend video a little bit it was just
a little uh
yeah a little a little you know a little
strokey uh i don't know
i don't know uh i just think uh this guy
may lose
one million dollars
if he puts that bet in i don't know zack
ertz uh
i don't know man anyway let's talk about
the dog legend
you saw the dog name is iverson that's
legendary already right in itself dog
name is iverson
i mean you guys saw the hezy around the
table has he has he has he
ended up on devonta adams loving the
pick
kelly devonte's been hot all year i
think he's been
scored in sixth straight right gabby
that's correct he's been hot
all year kelly so talk to us
as far as this game goes greg i don't
think i want to get involved i
i think look at eight and a half maybe
the packers were a play
now at nine nine and a half we're seeing
sharp money coming on the eagles
look i want no part of this one the
number one reason
i cannot back zach ertz why because we
saw how inept
that eagles offense is we saw it against
seattle which isn't
mediocre defense at best this year
speaking of good defenses
the packers defense can show up uh
i don't like the zachary's plate look if
you're gonna take the odds boost here
you've got to take advantage you can't
take a plus
three dollar dog you gotta take a bigger
favorite here
devonte adams number one wide receiver
for the packers
aaron rodgers go to i think this is an
easy one i think you take
devonte adams minus 155 you give me
three to one with devante
all day
cabbie i'm sorry i was just in the
comments looking at my handy dandy
notebook i don't know if you guys can
see but there's a there's a gift right
there i know you guys see it a little
bit there's a gift
and that's devonte adams my guy madeline
sent us a gift he's riding with devonta
adams you're welcome
walking away with the hoodie ethan dietz
says
dog legend lock it in
ethan just for that you're walking away
with the hoodie as well
cabbie i need one more just to confirm
ryan ryan
abedilia says devonta
adams adams
is moving on cabbie uh to the next round
in the dog legends shout out to iverson
i i'm i'm rocking iverson did that for
him so devonta adams and iverson and the
dog lives
moving on hopefully iverson gets all
those tasty treats that's awesome so
zach 13 and iverson and devonte adams
moving on to round two three more
opponents left you know how we do here
on the squad ride
let's get to round two our next pitch
comes from jay murhai
who summons something from beyond
yo i think my hotel's haunted i've been
hearing some weird noises
oh oh my god
i think it's the betting gods look at
this
dolphin cook anytime td score
be our betting there you go
candyman candyman candyman
listen you heard from the dog legend you
heard from the ghost legend
and i just uh recalled something
terrible from kelly's childhood
experience
um greg what was the when was the last
time you were ghosted
and i'm not talking about in football
ghosted
cabbie i i i'm not even going to speak
on that but i'm going to tell you what i
am going to speak on
i mean i'm i'm i'm terrified right now
kathy i'm honestly terrified
this guy went beyond the grave for his
pick he went beyond the grave for this
pick
and he tapped in with uh some ghosts i'm
i'm afraid if we do not select
dalvin cook in the ghost legend to move
on or to win the squad right he might
come send some of those uh
some of those uh spirits our way i hope
not
hope not but let's talk about the pick
dalvin cook he's minus 400 for a reason
he's minus 400 for a reason and you know
i mean you know what the show's about
anyway
kelly talk to me dalvin cook
devonta adams talk to me this this is
this is kind of a biased pick here now
i'm not betting the game
i do think that laying 10 with the
vikings is a little steep
could the vikings win 24-10 and cover
that number
absolutely and if they're gonna do that
they got to get
two touchdowns from dalvin cook we
cannot trust kirk cousins here
he's got a dink and dunk run the ball
with cook burn the clock which means
kind of looking at it towards an
undergame as well
uh yeah i mean dalvin cook three to one
odds boost
all day that this is a simple one for me
cabbie kelly i'm back into the comments
man
hey i don't know who started the trend i
don't know who's searching
but there's a ton of gifts going on in
the comments i don't know
you can see right new gifts in our
comments
look at devonta adams we also got dalvin
right there
someone started the trend keep the trend
going
we need to see gifts in the comments uh
shimmy burger is rocking with dalvin
cook
yes sir dalvin cook not one not two not
three
how about one more four td game the
betting guys are speaking and he's a
lock versus jacksonville
shimmy burger you're walking away with
the hoodie
cape doop carl or
2-3 dave coop carl at 2-3 is saying uh
he's cooking he's cooking up dalvin cook
cabbie he's cooking up dalvin cook in
the comments
i'm gonna cook you up a hoodie uh
not darius got another gif with your
dalvin hey cabbie i think we're just
we're we're calling it we're calling
okay
ghost legend dalvin cooks moving on to
the next round
everybody i said you're getting a hoodie
let's go well the ghost legend strikes
fear
into both kelly's heart and the heart of
the jacksonville defense
with dallin cook rushing the ball
because that dude has been impressive
in 2020. so the ghost legend moves on to
round three
and his opponent in route three is hey
big noah
who do you got locking in for a
touchdown in week 13.
anytime touchdowns for baseball edition
we got darling cook
travis kelsey aaron jones devonte parker
on the boss if it hits
the bucket on the fly it's a lock let's
go
[Music]
lock it up
yo what'd i say who wants to get rich
oh nice punctuation the walk-off was
vicious cabbie the walk-off was
hey cabbie we got to give this man some
credit we have to give him some credit
first off lefty southpaw pitching second
off he hit the bucket
on the second try that's not easy he's
standing about
60 maybe 90 feet you know
like that's not easy that's not easy to
do
but not only did he execute in the video
his pick happy let's talk about the pick
travis
kelsey i mean he's top three and
receiving and he's a tight
end come on the guy's balling this year
he's sitting at minus 125.
i might want to pull out my phone right
now but hold on before i do that
kelly talk to me talk to him oh great
guys
kelsey we got the biggest wide receiver
in the league
even though he's listed as a tight end
he is patrick mahomes number two
weapon and rightfully so look this is a
cheap price with kelsey i i don't hate
this bet
against that broncos defense that's just
been lackluster
at best now just remember this before
you go to lay the 13 and a half
last game in denver the final score was
rather fraudulent remember there was
not one but two defensive touchdowns a
special teams touchdown so
be a little cautious if you're going to
lay double digits here by all means
the chiefs should cover it yes travis
kelsey should score a touchdown
but remember it is a divisional game and
crazier things
have happened so if i'm gonna pick
between the two of these
i'm gonna take the non-divisional game
here and also i'm kind of biased i have
the minnesota vikings
in my big money survivor league there's
only 20 of us left i need a vikings w
which means i need alvin cook to score
two touchdowns
yes that's great i'm i'm actually
playing against dalvin cook so uh stay
low on the touchdowns but i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments kelly and
cabbie
t landry 828 says kelsey is a lock
i like that pick honestly i do like that
pick uh i'm getting a lot of kelsey
gifts in the comments getting a lot of
kelsey gifts in the comments
also seeing dalvin cook sean powell
you're walking away with a hoodie
imbron 2 you're also walking away with
hoodie for your gift cavi kelly it's
back and forth in the comments next one
i see i'm just gonna commit to it okay
okay i'm gonna scroll
i'm gonna scroll i'm gonna scroll and uh
dalvin cook look dalvin cook there it is
dalvin cook
is moving on you guys see it right there
on the screen dalvin cook is moving on
to the next round travis kelsey gave him
a run for his money but the people has
spoken
wow that's that was a close one because
both guys are huge touchdown threats for
their team so
salute to jay murhai the ghost legend
moving on to round three
we are about to meet your final opponent
whoever wins this next round
will be our squad ride in week 13.
our final pitch comes from our favorite
farmer riley sorbo
i can't wait for you guys to see this
one
bad ride picking we got tayson hill the
infinity gauntlet
dk metcalf on the hulk let's see what
we've got
you guys gonna pick one oh dang it looks
like taysom hill with the runaway
oh cabby
cabbie did you see the chicken he showed
bert right there you're not getting up
that high brother
you're not getting up that high no i bet
that right now
chicken just show vert oh my god old mc
legend just struck again
i cannot believe like oh they had the
fish there cabbie they had now
no not walk walk walk through this with
me they had to fist there
i don't know mike tyson roy jones jr
yeah that just happened
so maybe that was a little influenced by
that but uh
i think it's time we send the chicken
some hoodies man
why not we we let we open old mick
legend probably has like four hoodies
let's send this chicken some hoodies
it is a cold winter but yeah it is a
cold winter taste of hill though minus
143.
kelly talk to me talk to me taste some
hill dab and cook
what are you thinking where are you it's
priced all wrong great jason hill should
be plus money i know
everybody got mad at me on social media
because i said you should never in any
world lay 17
on the road with a backup quarterback
last weekend taysom hill
made me eat my words and scored two
touchdowns now
look at his price 143 in a divisional
game against the falcons
give me a break i'm taking the falcons
plus three i'm taking the falcons on the
money line
this is wrong wrong wrong take dalvin
cook
and the three to ones odds boost from
our friends at draftkings
this is a no-brainer all right well tell
us in the comments if you're
riding with the ghost legend and dalvin
cook as kelly just mentioned
or ole mic legend and taysom hill uh
while you do that look last week's game
wasn't pretty
for cam newton and the new england
patriots who are the home road dogs
but they won straight up against arizona
and straight up
when you rock with kelly stewart you
will build you will
knock some w's that will build your
bankroll so kelly stewart please give
the people
your best bet in week 13. thank you for
the kind words kathy look it's been
a rough start and now we started to hit
our stride right in the middle
of the season so we're going to keep it
going here i'm going to take the
washington football team
down to seven i bet this at plus
10 on tuesday that is some sharp money
some big money some respected money
that moved that line and why do we see
this line move well let's talk about the
pittsburgh steelers
they were supposed to play on
thanksgiving then they were supposed to
play on sunday then they were supposed
to play
on tuesday they finally played their
divisional rival the baltimore ravens on
tuesday
now this game gets moved to monday and
then
who do they have on deck that's right
another afc
team in the buffalo bills how much do
they care about the nfc leased
the answer is they don't the washington
football team has a really good shot i
think to win this game at home
and solidify their spot into the
playoffs which sounds absolutely absurd
but i think it's gonna happen i think
it's gonna be a really close game i'm
gonna call this a field goal type game
so even at seven
i think it's worth a flyer here and if
the game lands eight or nine you guys
can tell me how much you hate me all
over social media
we love you kels listen that schedule
has bounced around so much he actually
played
wednesday in a matinee game at 3 40
which is so because nbc had to show the
the christmas tree lighting but either
way uh pistor got the w
and with uh 10 days of preparation for
washington
they might play the role of spoiler for
an undefeated
season for those steelers but anyway get
on draftkings
lock in washington plus seven if you're
rocking with our mvp
kelly stewart now greg ivory you've been
reading the comments
you've been taking a temperature of that
final match up
uh you've been checking in with the
audience and you know the answer to this
question
what is our squad ride in week 13.
cabbie
they're back and forth in the comments
they're back they are
yeah let me just read a couple drew
mccaughey says
i got all my money on taysom hill dude
is playing like an absolute beast
yes drew i love that take oh yeah drew's
just
laying that in here he said it like five
times uh
here we go i got another one dalvin cook
all day you already know
how it is shimmy burger you have won a
uh
hoodie already but uh d-a-i-t-r-i-o-n-9
is rocking with taysom hill he says lock
it in cabbie
next one we're deciding next one we're
deciding um
here we go i see
b-tap uh-oh b-tab says he's rocking with
taysom hill
so much slime said he's rocking with
taysom hill cabbie it's a runaway now
take some hill it's who we're rocking
with uh
let's go man we're rocking with tasty
meal where's the graphic where is the
graphic
there the graphic is take some heal this
is not a passing touchdown
we're talking about a rushing touchdown
change the graphic please
it is now plus 300
odds boost and this only happens here i
want to repeat that this
only happens right here on the squad
ride where we get the odds boost
uh make sure you guys tune in to the br
instagram
stories where you can get on the story
send me your picks
but remember put it in the comments
yeah you guys know what to do remember
uh
here we go kathy let's let's keep going
they're gonna put it in the comments
they're gonna put an account yeah
you can also remember that tayson hill
scored four touchdowns in the last two
games so that dude is on fire thank you
very much
to our friends at draftkings for the
odds boos make sure to check out the br
betting social
instagram or twitter account for the
link to the odds boost that's very
important
send us your screenshots because we want
winners only please and we've been
getting some
wild parlays so keep that up thank you
to everybody
who commented uh thank you to those
people that won hoodies
and thank you to our legends every week
we got a new crop
loge mabry um zach13
j murhai the ghost legend hey big noah
and of course our favorite farmer
riley sorbo the videos just keep getting
better so we appreciate the creativity
of what you guys are sending us and um
listen
it's that time go bet on some football
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is kathy richards this has been
the squad hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold that was
just about to get out of here we got to
go make some wagers gee buddy before we
get out of here be
tapped 24 winners only please you're
walking away with any
rookie locksmith don't forget the please
you're walking away with a hoodie
t gibson winners only you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh ryan alvida you're walking away with
a hoodie w-m-k-4
you're welcome okay okay okay all right
buddy
at least they follow directions okay
okay i'm sorry
the people the people was talking to me
cabbie you know i just wanted to
and you and you you tapped into greg
claus a little bit early
save it for the for our christmas
treasure listen everybody
thank you very much for joining us and
thank you for watching the squad ride
good luck with your wagers and peace
[Music]
[Music]
you